le bêtisier ont toujours toujours comme
ta mère excellent
[Musique]
jeu long des mois et chargés d'ériger
une fiat fiat punto une claque panda
panda 500 break
je me suis fait baiser par
contre
qu'il a dit là bas nous fera pas des
merdes je me vois bien la démarrer mon
articulation j'entends parfois
sommes soumis leur salle polyvalente et
les charger de leur bourse de rebattre
savent tous qu'il va en des chercheurs
samsung les enlève les charges sommes
sûrs c'est que ça me sourit joël et
shine oui si on enlève
notre prochaine série j'ai mis un budget
de fou en tout cas pas dans tes cours de
théâtre aux
prochaines séries j'ai mis un budget 2,5
vous êtes le premier homme à être le
plus riche ça me rendait
s'il vous plaît je me suis effacé mais
au rythme des musiques
pas que chez because et d'ailleurs ont
ils osé origine bismarck
et le wild je sais pas
demandez pas ce qui se passe d'accord je
ne peux pas changer
et pas mal mais ta mère sauf est j'aime
bien mais oui on est en réunion tout en
restant inscrits chez nous alors et
louis l'aide ben je sais pas
demandez pas ce qui se passe d'accord je
ne peux pas changer bon
on fait que faire de
benoît xiv [ __ ] j'y
étais il était petit comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
mais le téléphone
deux fois prochaine télé ça va cartonner
j'espère que c'est pas encore
l'adaptation d'un an et demi en live
parce qu'elle coûte j'espère que ce
n'est pas encore un ami mais [ __ ] ça
va j'espère que ce n'est pas encore une
adaptation live
j'espère que c'est pas encore
crevé je viens de croiser à l'instant le
ministre du chômage de mini-cités
l'économie je viens de croiser alias
tout de même le ministre du chômage dans
les affaires étrangères pour la venue
passer dans deux dans julia à voile a
voulu passer dans deux dents dans les
fêtes on va cartonner
les réunions coupé g twitch
on s'est fait pirater quoi les hackers
ont dévoilé les salaires de tout le
monde les gens savent qu'on est en cas
de non les salaires des escrimeurs
à la russie qu'on reparlera plus tard
chez facebook on l'appelle le met à
vercel au travail à la
chaîne et pixi minable je te fous sur la
prochaine série ça va cartonner j'espère
que c'est pas encore l'adaptation
japonais parce que c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois c'est un four un lobby bob
death note
wingles saison de
ça chez les aînés vite et ça cartonne
dans les défaire regarde tout le pognon
qu'on se fait auquel suisse elle est par
contre juste comme ça parce que moi je
sais mais votre définition des nefs
c'est très simple c'est quand tu as mais
elle est née le 10 bien elle est belle
oui quand tu pars internat après tu
prends et je n'ai aucune idée de ce que
je fais de canal
prochaine
le sénat sur la question l'itinéraire
à bassar ou bien chez marvel pour le
nouveau spider man on va prendre dr
octopus et électro c'est impossible ah
oui ils viennent de différents reboot de
la franchise mais si grâce aux
gouttières
et vous moi je sais mais comment vous
définiriez
aux event risque que vous avez un nom
précis l'association s'il vous plaît les
neuf hommes de tête
[Musique]